the 90s were full of bucket hats boy
bands and television stars
but many of the tv icons of the era have
disappeared in the years since
you've probably thought about your 90s
favorites from time to time
so we've checked in on a few to see what
they're up to now
arguably the coolest teen on 90s tv
marla sokoloff rose to fame as stephanie
tanner's best friend geo on full house
she wore crop tops went to makeout
parties and even smoke
in short her character had attitude to
spare marla went on to star in whatever
it takes where she met
james franco who she ended up dating for
four years
her sitcom and film career was on fire
so where did marla sokolov go
the short answer is that she's been as
busy as ever even if it's been in
projects that may not put her in the
limelight
marla has had consistent work including
six seasons as lucy hatcher on the
practice
an assortment of television guest
starring roles and a slew of made-for-tv
movies
between 2016 and 2020 sokolov has also
reprised her role as
jia on the full house sequel series
fuller house making our 90s hearts swell
at the age of 11 tatiana ali lit up the
small screen as ashley banks
on the fresh prince of bel air we
watched her have her first kiss
belt out a song for a record label and
grow out her bangs
after fresh print ali expanded her
talents to the music industry and film
putting out the album kissed the sky in
1998 and appearing in the film
jawbreaker with rose mcgowan and judy
greer in the years following
ali made education her top priority and
she graduated from harvard with a
bachelor's degree in african american
studies in government
tatiana later married stanford professor
dr von raspberry and is a proud mother
of two
still she hasn't completely abandoned
the industry in recent years
she's branched out into producing and
her later acting credits include the
2018 holiday film jingle bell
plus get ready to break out your best
carlton dance tatyana and her castmates
got together for a fresh prince reunion
special on hbo max
before hermione granger there was
another big head overachiever
named tapanga lawrence on boy meets
world
[Music]
topanga
danielle fisher was the envy of every
90s kid until the sitcom ended in 2000.
while official had small roles on yes
dear and long shot after the series
ended
she ultimately found that good roles
just weren't coming her way
she took some time off from acting to
earn a psychology degree
worked at bloomingdale's got married
divorced and even received a dui
in 2008 she began to host the dish which
showcased her bubbly personality
more recently danielle reunited with her
old castmates on the boy meets world
sequel series girl meets world
remarried had a baby and has her eyes
set on the director's chair
sadly she didn't end up with ben savage
in real life
but it's nice to see her happy before
wikipedia
preteens had one go-to source of
information
clarissa melissa joan hart explained it
all and we loved every second of it
just when it didn't seem like she could
be any cooler hart took on the lead role
in sabrina the teenage witch
living with her two awesome aunts and
the best talking cat on tv
sabrina used her magical powers to get
through high school
even though those characters were
magical hart says she was only seen as
her iconic rose
and getting parts after sabrina was a
struggle during this frustrating time
she met her husband course of nature
lead singer mark wilkerson the couple
have been going strong ever since
and have three boys together in 2010
hart's acting career took off again
with a co-lead role in melissa and joey
alongside fellow 90s heartthrob joey
lawrence
hart has also been busy in the holiday
movie game as the lead in the sanicon
broadcasting christmas a very merry toy
store a very nutty christmas
christmas reservation and dear christmas
so for now
you can get your holiday cheer on with
melissa joan hart while you hold your
breath for that rumored clarissa
explains it all reboot
and speaking of classic nickelodeon
welcome to good burger home of the good
burger can i take your order
in the 90s you couldn't imagine a better
sketch duo than keenan and kell
we all know keenan thompson went on to
make us laugh every week on snl
but if you're wondering what happened to
the other half of the duo you're not
alone kel mitchell has actually had a
fascinating career since his time on
good burger he's now a voice actor
with his most famous role being t-boned
on clifford the big red dog
in 2019 mitchell also appeared on
dancing with the stars
and ended in second place another
surprising career turn came later in the
year when he announced he'd become a
licensed youth pastor
the father of three rediscovered his
faith after a struggle with drugs and
alcohol
he told people i was trying to figure it
all out on my own
but what i needed to do was turn to him
once i found that clarity with christ
i knew everything would work out lark
vorhees came into our lives as the
extraordinary lisa turtle on save by the
bell
afterwards vorhees made appearances on
shows like the bold and the beautiful
in the house and the parkers
unfortunately she also became part of a
national enquirer's scandal when the
publication claimed that voorhees was
hospitalized due to a cocaine addiction
locke filed a lawsuit suggesting that
she lost work because of their false
claims
she remained out of the limelight even
after the case concluded
and now for all the dirt the national
enquirer hasn't found out yet
here's lisa our galloping gossip
vorhees publicly said she'd like to be
involved with the save by the bell
reboot and those pleas have paid off
as she popped up on an episode of the
show we wish her the same amount of
happiness she brought all of us
in the 90s shane west burst into the tv
scene on the abc family drama once and
again
later leaving the small screen to take
roles in the films whatever it takes and
get over it and falling in love with
mandy moore in a walk to remember
he became an undeniable heartthrob and
then he was gone
but not really west actually went back
to his roots working regularly on
television
although the roles were a little
different than his fans were used to
after years of teen romance west decided
to leave that world behind and take on
grittier parts including roles on er
salem gotham and nikita west has also
continued to work regularly on the film
side of things
with a list of credits that includes the
thriller escape the field
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebs are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you